what up guys welcome to the Jazz pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to my biggest hate videos
from the time I don't know maybe the
last week two weeks I'm really excited
to get into it um now today I will be
identifying as Andrew Tate because
people have called me the female Andrew
Tate um so let's let's get into it let's
watch this hate video I got spoiled I
got spoiled in the other room so we need
to talk about Andrew Tate I've made
videos before about you know misogynists
like those Tick Tock dating coaches that
are like you need to dominate your women
and you need to you know tell them
they're a stupid I need videos on them
but they've never been this alarming
this is also one of the reasons alarming
that's a strong word lady on youth
attractive the reason 18 and 19 year
olds are more attractive than 25 year
olds because they've been through let's
check I'll say this right here on the
internet I don't give a [__] people sit
there and go oh you can't see bro we got
him it's not about being properties
about the fact that she belongs to him
and the end intimate parts of her body
belong to him because they're in a
relationship and if she wants to sell
those he has a stake in those parts of
her body so if you want to chop your
dick off I have nothing against that
leave the kids alone you can be as
transgender as you like don't come talk
to my kid about it yeah yeah yeah no
yeah no yeah if you haven't seen him
already you're welcome he's had a very
very significant impact especially on
social media hey go make me a sandwich
in the kitchen it's a joke okay females
don't deserve rights it's my opinion
does anyone in here watch entertain nope
okay then I'll just leave since everyone
wants me to freaking die this is why
men's mental health recently he was did
he seem like a beta to you beta beta
Googled his name is Googled more than
Trump more than Mr Beast Within Jake
Paul Joe Biden all these very very
influential people with very large
platforms he's surpassing them videos
have been posted about him or of him
saying these incredibly damaging and
like dangerous things I hate that these
words are damaging these words are
dangerous it's just like grow up you're
damaged by words how old are you like
she looks old I mean not old old but you
know like old enough you know people
used to go to war that used to be
damaging now words that's what you're
damaged by about women about gay people
about transgender people I mean
basically anyone that isn't an alpha
male like him he's talking about but
what's frightening about it is he has
support people are eating this up well I
mean not people but like a specific
group of people that he has targeted
they are loving Andrew they are loving
everything that he says everything that
he stands for everything that he's done
you know they're all about it they
really are little tiny fangirls they
support Andrew with their likes their
comments their interactions but also
literal physical money they give him
money they pay this man for what we're
gonna find out we're gonna talk about it
I'm gonna show you some of the
misogynistic things he said some of the
transphobic things he said some of the
homophobic things he said I'm going to
show you exactly why I think he is so
dangerous and also I feel like we need
to talk about how he's literally
scamming children I feel like that has
to be breaking some sort of law am I
wrong anyways I post new videos here on
my channel twice a week so if you guys
are not subscribed go ahead right now
I'm gonna say something I'm not saying
this to be offensive are you thinking
this is she
no don't cut it I'm asking what I didn't
say that's a bad thing
I can't be the only one thinking done
thank you very much so yeah with no
further Ado let's let's Chit Chat let's
get
[Music]
it how he has so many followers how he's
making so much money I mean honestly I
don't get it either those are my initial
thoughts as well don't worry from what
I've seen his followers are mostly young
boys giving James sorry and the reasons
that I've seen these young boys give for
you know why they support Andrew why
they love top G Tate I mean it's just
it's because he's
I don't know people like to be behind
someone that has a cause and a mission
and that's the cool thing about Andrew
trying to fight The Matrix y'all Fight
The Matrix oh [__] yes I'm sorry I mean
my producer reminded me I am Andrew I am
Andrew I need a little laugh break sorry
he's Rich allegedly he's successful
allegedly and this is the most alleged
one he sleeps with tons of women the sub
proclaims tons of women I guess they
redefine tons to be negative four sorry
that wasn't funny this is why Andrew
Tate thinks that women exception my girl
see I wish I could make this joke but
it's hard when you actually start to
know the people that you wanna okay
there are many
ugly Rich celebrities that sleep with a
ton of women you're telling me you don't
think that that's rich and famous can
get a lot of girls come on come on let's
just let's just come on teach
transphobic so he wouldn't think I'm a
girl so maybe men are I knew it I was
right you can't cut it don't cut it
that's what she just said she said she's
transfer he's transphobic how do I go
can you go back don't worry from what
I've seen his followers are mostly young
boys giving James Charles sorry and the
reasons that I've seen these young boys
give for you know why they support
Andrew why they love top G Tate I mean
it's just I just need a little laugh
break sorry he's Rich allegedly he's
successful allegedly and this is the
most alleged one he sleeps with tons of
women the self-proclaims tons of women I
guess they redefine tons to be negative
four sorry that wasn't funny this is why
Andrew Tate thinks that women aren't
except Andrew takes transphobic so he
wouldn't think I'm a girl did you think
she was hot before
I was right men aren't funny I think
that the main reason that these young
men are looking up to Andrew teen I'm so
funny the main reason that people are
looking up to him is because these young
boys want a role model they see somebody
that is super rich super successful has
tons of girls has tons of cars he's got
a Bugatti I don't I don't know what kind
of accident he has Romanian and these
young boys want one somebody strong and
successful that they can look up to but
two they want somebody to defend them
against this new wave of I don't want to
call it feminism because I I don't think
that this is a result of feminism but I
feel like a lot of the reason that these
young boys support Andrew is a result of
this wave of like men ain't [__]
man-hating Vibes you know what I'm
saying I'll just start out by saying
that men ain't [__] I'm just kidding but
it is a big thing that's going on right
now I see I think after the metoo
movement a lot of these men were like
now you can't talk to a woman you can't
approach them you can't you know have
sex with them or they'll regret it and
they'll ruin your life blah blah blah
it's those type of people that are very
much Pro Andrew Tate they want to
support somebody that's going to enable
them to do those things that they use no
and this is this is so wrong it's wrong
wrong wrong there are millions of men
that have had false accusations against
them they've had their lives and careers
destroyed like that happens every day
and you see that it's like one she you
are a dude like can we just that's one
and two it's like we have this lack of
empathy for men in society it was just
incorrect do and now get in trouble for
we hear it all the time on my channel
that there is this widespread attack on
masculinity and a widespread attempt to
you know rewrite what it means to be a
masculine man and rewrite what it means
to even just be a man and so Tate's
supporters latch onto him because he is
the person that is kind of like putting
his foot down saying No this is what a
strong masculine man is we you know what
these men do you know and if you don't
know he's going to tell you it is kind
of ironic though because Andrew has
become such a well-known name and it's
not a good way a definition of infamous
if you ask a girl if they know who
Andrew Tate is they'll either say no or
yes I hate that mother
hey I'd say I interviewed that guy I
mean I'd say that's me because I forgot
I'm Andrew I'm sorry I'm not doing this
thing well blessing person to do these
reactions with
say no or yes I hate them
who's out here trying to teach a man or
boy sorry how to get women and how to be
an alpha top Gmail like him when in
reality he's just teaching them how to
be a [__] monster and be single for the
rest of their lives how if you're
pursuing a girl and you tell her that
you're an Andrew Tate fan it's done
they're gonna not like you they're gonna
be turned off and honestly don't listen
to her don't listen to her a little
scared to start off simple I think that
Andrew he just doesn't like women
there's a joke going around on Tick Tock
about Andrew that uses that audio I
think this man is gay I really do that
boy is gay and I really believe that I
don't like that Trend I don't like that
audio I don't think that it's cute or
funny or like whatever to try to
emasculinate a man by calling him gay
didn't you ever see those commercials
don't call something gay so gay you know
you really shouldn't say that knock it
off he says the dumb stuff
like oh women are horrible drivers and
Men on average are much smarter and have
higher IQs both of these claims were
debunked literally in front of his face
it was so funny put those clips in those
are funny do you think women are as
smart as men well it's been proven that
the smartest people in the world are men
proven how to read the study what study
bro Google it I'm gonna google it every
single study says there's no difference
if you look up the highest IQs in the
world the first 10 first 20 look them up
are they men or women I haven't done
this look it up I just highest IQ in the
world literally what comes up Marilyn
Von Savant as one of the world's highest
IQs she is known as the smartest person
in the world cool then then all right
cool then I'm totally wrong I never even
said people are listening to look at
outcome who has the most out like does
IQ matter what does IQ usually equate to
money now Jordan Peterson talks about
this a lot it's like basically your IQ
determines the two things that factor
into lifetime success is
conscientiousness and IQ I'm very
unconscious conscientious so I don't
know how the hell I got here but but
when it comes to IQ that's one of the
number one indicators of success now
let's look at the richest men in the
world and the richest women in the world
how did the women get there marriage
yeah interesting you can leave a
marriage and then you get paid like what
how do we get here you know but you're
still wrong and that's the problem I
disagree with you do you want to be
right or do you want to keep speaking
into a hug box where people agree with
you you know well if you just completely
devalue empirical evidence Actuarial
Sciences the entirety the insurance oh I
heard about this I heard it's actually
because women Drive less than men like
men get into more accidents but it's
like or like men get into more accidents
but it's because they drive more that's
what I heard it's industry that relies
on making these sorts of calculations to
ensure that these quotes are as
profitable as possible which ends up uh
charging men higher rates than women is
a statistical likelihood that men are
more dangerous drivers than women across
the board and get into more car
accidents across the board if you're
going to look at all of that and say it
doesn't matter because that does not
correspond to my own personal uh my own
personal experience so I have mixed
feelings about this okay I believe
there's an agenda behind study and I
believe that you can and this is just
anecdotal take this or leave it I
believe there's an agenda behind studies
and I believe that you can get a study
to say anything now it's hard because I
do cite a lot of numbers all right I
know I know it really depends like where
you get the numbers from and I believe
that there are a lot of places that give
you stats that don't make sense and they
they use the numbers in a misleading way
I'll give you an example one stat that I
hear often is that men that actually
fight for their kids get their kids but
they don't look at why the men don't
fight for their kids I'm doing this
documentary right now in the court
system and I don't want to get too into
it because it's a very long story but to
make a long story short why would a guy
spend his life savings to fight for his
kids and only have a 10 chance of
getting them does isn't that not a wise
decision but they don't talk about that
then you're silly you're being silly
you're being a silly person if everyone
thought like you did right we would have
no scientific achievements on this
planet we would still be living inside
caves how are you gonna say Google it
and like make this whole big thing like
I know what I'm talking about Google it
and then be wrong then of course there's
a standard guys just like anecdote it's
like some things we don't need we don't
need uh study for it's like water is wet
come on better but we're always on our
phone we're always like texting texting
what are you doing instead of driving
come on Superior beings and sexually
motivated and should be allowed to sleep
with whoever they want while in a
relationship and you as the girlfriend
should be 100 okay with that but also
you have to remain 100 loyal you've also
said that you could have multiple
partners but a female that was with you
couldn't also have multiple partners I
would personally find that revolting
correct but there are women who find
well I say revolting I think man is uh
sexual is not sexually exclusive it's
not the same as a woman is because with
a woman you have the paternity issue
with a man you don't have a paternity
issue if I have three girlfriends and
they all get pregnant we know who the
mother and who the father is if you have
one woman and three men you don't know
who even the parents are if she got
pregnant yeah you could definitely
figure that out DNA tests are pretty
accessible nowadays of course yeah
that's exactly it so I said science
could step in and fix it but that
doesn't mean it's not Haram and against
the will of God look read the Bible
every single man had multiple wives not
a single woman had multiple husbands
it's against the will of God it's
disgusting you know this is kind of
interesting to me because like what's
the point you're not loyal to her
sexually because you know you're a man
duh but then you're avoiding emotionally
as well again because you're an alpha
male and are too logical for him I mean
let's just look at this I'm not even
saying this is right or wrong I there's
a lot of like money duh gold diggers and
you know to say that look at many women
love their husbands and sometimes their
husbands cheat I'm not saying this is
right or wrong I'm just saying what
happens at
the Hallmark of being a man is the
ability to restrict your emotions the
difference between a man and a woman is
that you suppress your emotion true true
and I think some problems in society is
trying to get men to behave like women
yeah is that my eyelash literally coming
off cut the camera but like what is left
after that being able to say that you
own a woman oh yeah he thinks that women
are property too check that out you say
a lot of stuff about women like that
they're your property that's not what I
said I was talking about only fans
company when that was question was asked
but I said that if a woman is going out
with a man she belongs to that man
that's his woman so she wants to do only
fans she owes him some money because
she's his well that's crazy that one's
crazy if you so you think that a man
going out with a girl that that's just
your property he is his girl what was
that of doing because she's his they
would take this so out of context come
on every every girl wants to belong to
someone like what do you want to be with
a guy that doesn't want to claim you I
don't know I think they take that out of
context that is you saying that women
are your property it's not about being
property it's about the fact that she
belongs to him and the intimate parts of
her body belong to him because they're
in a relationship and if she wants to
sell those he has a stake in those parts
of her body so it's reverse a male porn
star owes the woman
this for but yeah very very cringy
woman-hating stuff it's like the
womanator club like from The Little
Rascals except like with guns and money
but the woman hating does not stop there
babe no no no no no no no you can see my
nothing he said was women hating none
none of that was women hey
he takes it much farther than other
online and says
[__] like this women aren't as big as me
below female
55 kilo fever
and when I'm standing on top of you and
you're like and I'm grabbing you by your
neck and you've learned I learned in
self-defense when you cross me by my
neck what I do is I get my fingers in
yeah but you know what that little
teachers oh my God I agree with that I
have said this before if someone's
breaking into my house and they send me
a female police officer I'm pissed I'm
pissed what is she gonna do I'm a six
guys okay this is me I am a six foot
female I have deadlifted roughly 300
pounds I've benched a plate okay I am a
strong ass girl an average guy could
beat me up easily I don't care what
self-defense classes you've taken if a
dude punches you in the face you're
gonna be knocked the hell out it's
defense here's a little move when I grab
you by your neck and you start annoying
me trying to resist okay this part I
don't even want to make a joke about
this is not funny this is not cute this
is not good advice to be giving anybody
but you are literally teaching men to
abuse women I really don't oh my God
he's kidding now this man is still
online like he has been accused of the
worst things he said that quote unquote
victims need to take accountability for
their assaults oh and also that he only
dates that is not it's like you take
accountability for anything I I
guarantee I already know let's see let's
see if he Clips it or 18 to 19 years old
because they've been through less dick
and they're easier for him to make his
imprint on where the 19 year old might
have had one guy from high school just
broke up she's fresh and I could
probably put my imprint on her make her
a good person and without her having to
go through all that detriment to learn
about life somebody called the [__]
police he literally said at one point
that 40 I think it was either 40 or 60
of the reason that he moved to Romania
was because the police there were less
likely to follow through on sexual
assault cases this is probably 14 of the
reason I moved to Romania because in
Eastern Europe you don't know the police
is saying oh he's not talking about
about me too he's talking about these
women going to the police with no
evidence and somehow being taken
seriously it's like yesterday okay if
you've got physical evidence or is there
CCTV proof where'd it happen Okay let's
go interview him right now and if it
wasn't really right oh we went to the
club we got drunk she agreed to go back
to my house we started having sex and
then we carried on having sex and then
we had sex and she didn't say anything
wrong and then she texts me afterwards
and I didn't text back and now she's
saying all right please be like okay no
not in the West in the west you can tell
them that exact story you're still
[__] you're [__] in the west when
people say why didn't Romania and I
explain my five reasons one of them is
the metoo air they go oh well
I like the idea of being able to just
say to do what I want I like being free
and if you're a man living in England or
Germany or America or any of the western
world right now you've decided to live
in a country where any woman any ex any
oh Andrew it's a little it's a sad now
isn't it it's like he thought Romania
still did him dirty she works at Greg's
we bought a pasty from
some point in the future can destroy
your life this metoo era bullet has not
protected women it's just destroyed the
safety of men so sure it's giving you
need to be in jail Andrew tell us the
real reason you don't date women your
own age maybe women your own age are
more experienced and less likely to deal
with your abuse oh maybe you're insecure
about women your own age maybe noticing
something lackluster oh Andrew
because men are attracted to younger
women can we just get over it like maybe
that's a girl there's always men that
are older than you so if you're 40 you
can date men that are 60. I mean if
you're 70 it's like yeah it's kind of
over but but it's just like you could
either complain about the rules or start
playing the game ladies obviously Andrew
has made many many comments about women
online which we have seen but he's also
made comments about gay people and about
transgender people and what kind of
trans content creator would I be if I
didn't respond to these claims leave the
kids alone if you want to chop your dick
off I have nothing against that I'm not
anti-gay I'm not anti-game transgender
I'm not anti-any of these things what
I'm what I am anti is propagating your
worldview on other people's children if
you're gay and you can't have kids why
do you now believe it's your right to go
to other people's kids and tell them how
to think if you've decided that the type
of sex you want to have will prevent you
from recreating from procreating that's
your decision right you've decided that
having sex with women isn't worth it for
you you don't want to have children you
want to have sex with men fine your
decision and you're entitled to it that
does not give you the entitlement to go
to other people's families who did
decide to have children and raise them
and try and program their children leave
the kids alone you can be as transgender
as you like don't come talk to my kid
about it that's my child I agree I agree
you should be able to protect your kids
from whatever information you see fit so
the these kids they want to teach you
about gay stuff in school why like why
does a 10 year old need to know what gay
is why program my child with my World
Views I raise them I pay for them
they're my kid they're not your kid and
then all the government's kid this whole
propaganda thing it's like it reminds me
of that audio and Tick Tock that is
literally all that goes through my head
all the time is your photos but it
reminds me of that audio that's like
they're teaching kids this stuff in
school yo some people do
Tick Tock of like the sex educator once
and she literally was talking about all
the pleasure stuff on girls and guys and
I was just like lady why did the
teenagers like why do they need to know
this do you want them teaching blessing
your kid about pleasure stuff no he's
shaking his head is that is that fun for
like even a 15 16 year old the teachers
it's like that's that to me that leaves
room if you were okay this is a weird
thought to have right but if you were a
predator that's like the perfect job for
you teach kids
I've been banned sex ed in schools I
went to Catholic school we had no
unplanned pregnancies well maybe one
girl but in four years that's pretty
good that's pretty good she transferred
um so you know playing Tick Tock that
says that please giant cult like
brainwashing they're teaching
five-year-olds how to suck in public
school what school is that let me write
it down now let's hear what he had to
say about trans people I'm so excited
beginning when we have this whole Muslim
debate someone was saying to me their
countries are crazy and I say okay their
countries are crazy but they're not
dropping their sons off we're getting to
a point where almost you can view some
parts of our culture and we're more
crazy than anybody chopping their son's
dicks off somebody bring me some tequila
God damn imagine your father actually
don't imagine it because it sounds
traumatic but imagine your father just
coming into your bedroom the cleaver
like I'm time to get searched up this
Framing and this phrasing of it is also
very very misleading though describe a
trans individual as somebody's son
you're infantilizing them purposely to
consume a narrative that you know trans
people are coming for your children and
they're they're coming to chop your kids
go up Sir what motive would I have for
this to even have more people be trans
what would the motivation be do you know
that we're in a hormone shortage okay
but now besides all of the horrible
horrible things that Andrew Tate says
consistently there is another major
reason that I feel like he is especially
damaging husband University Hustlers
University is taints I mean Tate sorry
is I love it when people with no
Solutions criticize people's Solutions
you know so many people came at fresh
and fit for their Solutions but it's
always like people that offer nothing
it's like if you don't have a better
solution shut up
it's University or his online course or
whatever you want to call it that helps
you the student at home become a top G
like him it shows you the path from
baroki is this the left or right it
shows you the path from Brokey to top G
alpha male daddy taint Tate I mean no
but basically it's a pyramid scheme
anybody who buys into Hustler's
University is given the opportunity to
become an affiliate for the course as an
affiliate you make 50 of anybody else
you refer to the program so Tate is at
the top people below paid full price
they make 50 from the people they refer
they make 50 from people they refer you
see what I'm saying and the course is
all about making money online and one of
the primary methods that they teach is
cutting up clips of Tate to use across
social media to drive traffic I'm sorry
this was a genius this idea of his was
genius as an affiliate marketer to the
course so through doing this Tate has
created an army of people who are
pushing his content because they're
financially motivated to do so he is
recruiting young boys purposely is it
purposely or purposefully are they are
those both words purposely mean means on
purpose or Not by accident while
purposefully means indicating the
existence of a purpose that's that that
is deep
um I think that he did it both purposely
and purposefully like I was saying he
has purposely purposefully recruiting
these young vulnerable boys to be in his
online cult I mean course to then
continue to spread his message for him
bringing new followers for him new
students for him and make money for him
I mean yeah they get like a cut or
whatever but like it's a pyramid scheme
aren't pyramid schemes illegal
pyramid schemes are illegal oh it's
state by state though pyramid schemes
prosecutions are charged as felonies in
federal court and can be charged as both
a misdemeanor or a felony in California
shit's illegal maybe I shouldn't say
that it's a pyramid scheme because that
will get me in trouble it's allegedly
appearance and all of the interviews or
little podcast cities on he's always
like no anybody can join I don't I don't
you know Market it towards any specific
person whatever whatever what what's
this Andrew the only people who
genuinely adore you when you have a
Lamborghini and they see it drive past
and they start and their eyes light up
and they start waving their hands and
they'll do anything to get in your car
or 10 year old boys so I'm not sure
there's no point buying a Lamborghini
per to get buy it because you enjoy
yourself he talks about how the only
people that care that you have Bugattis
and like that are young boys while
filming this literally right now I can
look at his Instagram and the last post
is of his Bugatti you literally just
told on yourself from Miss Hustler's
University this pyramid scheme whatever
see this is what I mean reaction
channels will clip stuff together to
spin a narrative Andrew Tate's always
talking about his Bugatti and now he's
saying oh well it's it's to get the fans
or whatever but it's like they'll
they'll put their world view on Clips
like that's what these place these
people do he has created a swarm I
almost said like Army but I feel like a
swarm is more appropriate like little
bugs you know he's created a swarm of
little taints I mean Tates that go
around and Bully and attack anybody that
stands up and stands out against you
know things that Andrew has said they
also perpetuate these negative attitudes
these negative stereotypes and these
negative actions towards women so yeah
if you see this Andrew Tate Guy online
on I'm sure you will I'm sure you
already have um just be aware well guys
um I forgot I was pretending to be
Andrew this whole thing but this was a
lot of fun I think that this is crazy
and I I knew I knew that was a I know
yeah blessing you better not cut it you
better not cut it like the video on your
way out guys subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time